there's a lot of talk about inflation
these days inflation i don't know things
are getting crazy i don't know the
inflation inflation we hear it all the
time but what can you actually do about
it here's what warren buffett has to say
about that
although and
although individuals can avoid inflation
it is what it is legendary war investor
warren buffett says there are two things
that people can do to help protect
against it number
one
he says the best things a person can do
to protect against inflation is to
sharpen their skills and work to be at
the top of their field
top of their field he's not giving
investment advice he's not telling you
what to buy he's basically saying be the
best
version of yourself
that's recession proof yeah that's
inflation proof if you're the best
teacher doctor lawyer businessman
entrepreneur
production coordinator yeah there's
always going to be an opportunity for
you always be the best at what you do
inflation-proof okay
he says if you're the best teacher if
you're the best surgeon if you're the
best lawyer kind of what i was saying
you will get your fair share of the
national economic pie regardless of the
value of whatever the currency may be if
you're good you're going to get paid
right
straight up abs i mean yeah i mean it's
hard to argue with that it's hard to
argue that okay all right
the next best course of action this is
number two the next best course of
action to protect against inflation this
is according to mr buffett let's put
respect on his name
on mr buffett he says to own part
of a wonderful business what a wonderful
business you should be a part of that's
because no matter what happens
with the value of the dollar the
business product will still be in demand
own businesses a lot of times when he's
talking about not only should you can be
a business owner yeah he talks about
investing in stocks and stocks are just
companies and companies are just
businesses and investing in stock so i'm
reading two ways into that actually
owning a business or owning pieces of
business as shares of stock
right uses this one what's that sorry
someone in the comments that invest in
uh better internet
okay we will we're working i think we
literally just did that yeah no it
wasn't even the internet okay it was the
software gotcha love that software talk
anyway
buffett uses one of his own investments
as an example he says if you own
coca-cola company right you don't coke
you will give it you'll be given a
portion of the people's labor 20 years
from now and 50 years from now your
product and it still doesn't make any
difference what happened to the price
level because people will still pay for
the products they like basically saying
rather than being victim of inflation
beat them to the curb
beat them to the punch
own the companies that are
inflation and recession proof coca-cola
that's one of them okay just there you
go just anyway i love that advice warren
buffett is talking that talk yeah you
know what he's talking about look
everyone out there today is trying to
get rich quick
everyone's trying to get rich quick what
ward buffon is saying is look i like to
build wealth slow i don't think that
warren the majority of warren buffett's
wealth came after
age 60. yeah
right yeah so good things take time let
the let the meta pasta sauce the
marinara marinate for a little bit
absolutely everyone's trying to get the
doge to be a dogecoin billionaire it's
because you you hear so many things
about like oh i traded xyz
cryptocurrency and i'm a millionaire so
everyone's like how do i
get that now it's so easy i don't want
to fall into that trap but
i love his advice of just being the best
just what you can be a specialist not a
generalist don't be a jack of all trades
double down on what you're good at and
the market will pay you all right thank
you mr buffett
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broke